c'est la vraie question à se poser cette
année faut-il acheter un smartphone 5g
en 2020 de plus en plus de constructeurs
proposent des smartphones 5g la voyez
j'ai trois nouveaux smartphones sont
sortis il n'ya pas longtemps on le voit
une +8 pro 5 g/j aux milices pro 5 g et
on a le web et 40 pro 5 j'ai donc la 5g
arrivent de partout
on va donc faire un point pour savoir
s'il faut acheter un smartphone 5g en
2020 jeudi 2020 mais c'est également
valable pour début 2009 un t1 à la fin
de la vidéo je vous donner une réponse
claire et vous allez voir c'est pas
forcément ce qu on pourrait s'attendre
on va commencer extrêmement simplement
par re situer ce qu'est la 5g la 5g
c'est la cinquième génération de
communication mobile à 5 g vient
succéder à la kadji qui elle même avait
succédé à la 3g à la 2g alors bref vous
comprenez un peu l'histoire ce qu on
fait comme promesse avec la 5g sont des
débits significativement augmenté donc
une collection beaucoup plus rapide
une latence beaucoup plus faible mais ça
c'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg
puisque la 5g
c'est beaucoup plus que ça mais avant
toute chose il faut distinguer deux
types de 5 g il y à la 5g
seuls 6 qui sera être plus une évolution
de la 4g et vous avez la 5g
millimétriques qui est fera vraiment la
5g la plus intéressante 5 euros en débit
absolument incroyable une latence
extrêmement faible mais qui par contre a
vraiment de très courte portée
le concept de 5 g en lui-même est
beaucoup plus complexe que juste de
parler de 5g la 5g n'est pas seul il ya
différents types de 5 g il ya également
la 5g stand alone l'a5 génome stander
enfin jeunes vous passez un peu le detec
technique normalement la vraie année de
la 5g l'année dans laquelle la 5g arrive
en tout cas en france métropolitaine
c'est 2020 elle est déjà arrivé dans
d'autres pays notamment en suisse on
peut la retrouver en corée du sud il ya
pas mal de pays qui ont déjà commencé à
développer la 5g sur la question
purement française il devait y avoir le
21 avril une attribution des fréquences
entre orange bouygues telecom sfr
il y à free sauf que à cause de la crise
du coronavirus cette date a été reportée
à une date ultérieure qu'on ne connaît
pas actuellement
ça dépendra bien évidemment de la durée
de la crise de la gestion n'est donc pas
mal de points en suspens ce qui veut
donc dire que l'arrivée de la 5g de fin
2020 me semble être un petit peu plus
délicate et là je vous parle de la
france il n'y a pas que la france c'est
la même chose en autriche portugal
espagne et pologne donc l'arrivée de la
5g fin 2020 risque d'être un petit peu
décalé ça devrait quand même allés assez
rapidement je pense que les opérateurs
ont vraiment poussé derrière pour que ça
aille vite et dès lors qu'on aura un peu
plus de débilité par rapport aux
questions sanitaires je pense que
l'arrivée de la 5g
on reviendra très rapidement sur le
tapis là je vous parle de la france
métropolitaine et si vous regardez l'île
de la réunion la 5g n'était pas prévue
avant début 2010 21 en belgique
2021-2022 en martinique guadeloupe et
guyane pas avant 2022 donc autant vous
dire que la 5g va arriver pas la même
vitesse selon les pays
donc on est vraiment sur une question de
déploiement progressif mais jean revenir
avant toute chose sur ce que vous allez
réellement pouvoir faire la 5g
quels sont les usages derrière la 5g
puisque se poser la question d'acheter
un smartphone 5g en 2020 ou en 2021 et
même dans les années à venir sera encore
plus le cas
il faut d'abord savoir qu'est ce que va
réellement vous apporter cette
technologie alors je vous disais des
débits plus rapides une latence plus
faible c'est surtout une vraie évolution
technologique mais également sociétale
ça vous permettra très simplement
d'avoir de la 4k et de l'a8 cas partout
ça va surtout et l'explosion du créneau
gaming vous pourrez vous déplacer avec
votre smartphone n'importe où vous aurez
accès à vos jeux très rapidement sans
aucune latence ça permettra à la réalité
virtuelle et à la réalité augmentée de
se développer réellement ça sera aussi
une très grosse avancée pour l'industrie
l'évolution de la robotique l'évolution
de la smart city ça sera également
l'évolution de la voiture autonome
c'est également l'évolution de la
domotique en fait la 5g permettra
d'avoir toujours plus d'appareils
connectés on va arriver à un niveau de
saturation avec l'acadie au bout d'un
moment on ne pourra plus avoir ton
appareil la 5g permettra d'en savoir
d'avantagé des lions buck avec la crise
du coronavirus il ya un essor qui énorme
du télétravail des conférences à
distance une utilisation accrue des
réseaux sociaux youtube netflix qui ont
diminué leurs qualités pour pouvoir
répondre à cette demande croissante ça
c'est vachement intéressant parce que la
crise du corona virus elle va donner un
nouvel élan à la 5g elle va permettre de
justifier tous ces besoins le fait
d'avoir de plus en plus d'appareils
connectés là où la 4g a du mal à y
répondre la solution pourrait bien se
trouver dans la 5g on retourne dons
à notre question essentielle faut-il
acheter un smartphone 5 g maintenant en
tout cas en 2020 voix en 2021
pour ça il faut qu'on se projette un peu
dans le temps nous on est ici en 2030
il devrait y avoir une couverture de la
5g à 100% on devrait donc avoir la 5g
par tout autre échéance 2025
les opérateurs devront avoir basculé
l'équivalent de leurs réseaux actuels
quand je dis devront ça peut être un
petit peu avant 2024
ou peut-être 2023 ayant 2025 vous aurez
également les zones urbaines et
économique c'est à dire toutes les
grandes villes qui devront être liées à
la 5g mais également la plupart des axes
routiers
chez nous la 5g elle devait arriver
initialement à la fin de l'année 2020
sauf qu'avec la crise du corps des virus
on risque pas de le voir arriver là on
sera plutôt à mon avis sur des bus amis
2021 si on part du principe qu'un
smartphone a une durée de vie de trois
ans et si vous achetez votre smartphone
en 2020 eh bien il va vous emmener
jusqu'en 2023 2023 ça veut dire que
potentiellement tous les opérateurs
n'auront pas basculer l'équivalent de
leurs réseaux actuels sans de la 5g ça
c'est en 2025 ça veut dire qu'il ya deux
années qui nous séparent 2025 néanmoins
les termes sont très claires c'est
devront avoir basculé
donc s'ils le font avant tant mieux la
saq j'y arriverai en 2021 dans cinq à
dix villes françaises bien évidemment
les plus grandes 2022 2023 2024 la
couverture vers de plus en plus grande
dans de très nombreuses villes jusqu'à
arriver en 2025 sans l'équivalent du
réseau actuel donc si vous achetez votre
smartphone en 2020 ou 2021 vous allez
arriver jusqu'en 2023 voire
potentiellement 2024 ici vont être
touchés les grandes villes les villes un
peu plus moyenne d'autres villes encore
d'autres villes jusqu'à arriver en 2025
vous allez trouver l'équivalent de
laquelle jacques thuel en termes de
couverture sur les années qui suivent
vous y retrouver une évolution de la 5g
avec la 5g
sauf si ce qui sera quasiment partout
mais également avec la salle g
millimétriques
ça veut donc dire que le fait de prendre
un smartphone 5g et un abonnement 5 g
chez votre opérateur ça va de soi va
dépendre de l'endroit où vous habitez
si vous habitez à paris lyon marseille
ou bordeaux j'imagine que vous pourriez
prendre l'abonnement 5 g d
et prochaine tout en ayant bien
évidemment smartphone 5 g si par contre
vous prévoyez de déménager au fin fond
du cantal à la fin de l'année j'embrasse
tous les gens qui vivent dans le cantal
et bien moment vous risquez de ne plus
avoir votre couverture 5 g si vous
habitez tout de suite au fin fond du
cantal ou de la lozère est bien la 5g
c'est pas forcément tout de suite pour
vous maintenant la question faut-il
néanmoins acheter un smartphone 5 g si
vous n'avez pas une perspective rapide
d'abord une couverture réseau 5g et
c'est là que se poser la vraie question
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non les
choses sont très claires les smartphones
5g arrivent ils arrivent en début
d'année par le très haut de gamme et par
le haut de gamme
ils vont continuer à arriver dans
l'année 2020 par le milieu de gamme et
ensuite ça va continuer à la fin de
l'année avec l'entrée de gamme donc la
plupart des smartphones qui sortiront en
2020 seront 5 g ça sera pareil avec une
accélération 2021 donc un moment ou un
autre ça va être impossible en tout cas
très difficile de couper aux smartphones
5e et maintenant il existe deux cas de
figure le premier cas de figure c'est
celui de samsung qui a sorti trois
smartphones dans le très haut de gamme
en début d'année s20 s20 plus s20 ultra
le s20 ultra et 5g uniquement cinq jets
d'eau comme ça le débat est clos pour
celui là par contre si vous regardez le
s20 et de s20 plus il existe dans deux
configurations 4g ou 5 g pourquoi est ce
qu'ils ont fait ce choix là parce qu'ils
sont dit que dans le monde entier la 5g
n'étaient pas présentes partout ils en
ont vraiment segmenté samsung est une
entreprise sud coréenne et en corée du
sud et la 5g donc là bas vous pourrez
acheter votre smartphone 5g sans aucun
problème par contre si vous habitez en
france par exemple
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas la 5g
dont vous vous dites ok je n'ai pas
acheté le smartphone 5 g qui va coûter
100 euros de plus je vais acheter le
smartphone 4g qui me gratte très bien
d'autant plus que la 5g ne l'a pas pour
arriver partout
donc ça c'est la première logique mais
très peu de marques qui ont fait ce
choix là deuxième cas de figure vous
prenez au web vous prenez xiaomi où vous
prenez one plus ils sortent des
smartphones d'entrée de gamme qui sont
uniquement des smartphones 5 g pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont une vision globale en
partant du principe que ses smartphones
marche seront aussi bien sûr de la 4g
que sur de la 5g puisque de nombreux
pays où ces smartphones sont
commercialisés la 5g et présentent ils
doivent donc répondre présent aux
besoins de 5 g et les autres pays bien
c'est pas grave auront la cad jpy que
ses smartphones seront également
encadrés ils ont peut-être pas voulu
faire le choix de samsung de faire deux
versions qui leur coûterait plus cher à
industrialiser et mon avis c'est le
deuxième cas de figure
lui de huawei one + et chimiques on
retrouvera le plus à savoir vous aurez
des smartphones 5g que vous pourrez
également utiliser avec de la 4g alors
ça c'est bien mais il faut quand même
savoir qu'un smartphone 5g coûte plus
cher qu'un smartphone 4g le modem 5
gilles va coûter un peu plus cher comme
modèle 4g la 5g va générer plus de
chaleur donc falloir refroidir votre
smartphone et en plus la salle j apporte
un peu plus de poids à votre smartphone
bon un petit peu plus c'est pas non plus
énorme
et là on touche le point central puisque
le problème est déplacé le problème
n'est plus faut-il acheter un smartphone
5g en 2020 2021
la question est plus ge acheter un
smartphone qui est de la 5g en 2020 et
je vous prends ces trois smartphones
parce que c'est ce que j'ai actuellement
qui ont de la 5g n'aurait d'autre vous
aurez bien évidemment montré j'ai trouvé
que shiomi afin super boulot avec son
mii 10pro d'ailleurs vous invite à lire
mon test si vous n'avez pas vu si vous
voulez donc se met dix pros qu'il est
compatible 5 g mais que vous n'avez pas
la 5g chez vous et bien devez vous ne
pas l'acheter
malgré qu'il vous fait de l'oeil et
malgré que au delà de la 5g ils cochent
toutes les cases de vos besoins
c'est la même chose pour moi ouais avec
notamment son fait 40 trop et la même
chose avec one plus pour notamment sont
même plus suit donc la réponse à la
question faut-il acheter un smartphone
5g en 2020 elle la réponse est non mais
peut-on acheter un smartphone 5g en 2020
la réponse est oui oui mais pas pour les
usages liés à la 5g
ça serait dommage de se priver de bonnes
technologies d'un bon smartphone d'ambon
photophone d'un bel écran d'une bonne
autonomie d'un smartphone puissant et
performant parce qu'ils les singes est
compatible et que vous vous ne captez
pas la 5g tous les smartphones qui vont
sortir à court et moyen terme auront de
la 5g vous ne pourrez donc pas coupé à
acheter des smartphones ac de la 5g même
si vous n'avez pas un réseau 5g à côté
de chez vous donc la question d'acheter
un smartphone uniquement parce qu'il a
de la 5g parce que ça pourrait vous
poser un problème
et bien en fait c'est un faux problème
si le smartphone vous plaît ça
technologies est bonne si smartphone
répond à vos besoins
et bien vous pouvez oui acheter un
smartphone 5 g mais pas pour les h 30
j'ai peut-être dans un an deux ans
ou trois ans vous en aurez l'utilité
réelle de la 5g passera peut-être pour
le smartphone qui arrivera après mais se
priver aujourd'hui le smartphone tant
que j'ai juste parce qu'il a de la 5g
je trouve ça dommage par contre un
smartphone 5g coûtera plus cher qu'un
smartphone 4g on le voit notamment avec
samsung avec année qu'à 200 euros entre
rs 24 grs 25 g à la question faut-il
acheter un smartphone 5 g en 2020 la
réponse est oui mais pas pour la 5g
j'espère que ça vous aura aidé à vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez vous en
bas en commentaire et d'ailleurs si vous
souhaitez acheter un smartphone 5g je
vous ai mis une liste de produits en bas
dans la description d'habitat digital
petit coup d'oeil sur ce je vous
embrasse ce rendez-vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler tech débit d'eau
canaux
[Musique]